there's a star trek next generation that
has that yeah one episode i need you to
see it
well it's really good he loves to watch
me suffer
please don't let that oh yeah because i
i swear to [ __ ] god
that my leg still [ __ ] hurts what
you mentioned this last night so what
happened six days ago i
you know i like to wrestle okay we know
all that and i was wrestling around with
kalila
and she got an angle on me and she did
one of her
muay thai tie heel um
hammered down those are [ __ ] hard no
it was a very standard classic american
dead leg
it wasn't no muay thai it hit me
right where all the nerves project into
this one
you know what i mean area also what did
you do that that warranted that kind of
aggression nothing
do you know what he did i had been on
the phone with spectrum and i
hate oh yeah
[Laughter]
i hate calling any type of like phone
company she's been on for like 30
minutes on the spectrum
all right on live okay and he's driving
me crazy i put it on speaker and i put
it right next to me because i'm like
look i'm not going to put it to my phone
like this
for 30 minutes and that's because we
need wi-fi and all that stuff in the new
house
but he doesn't that's not part of his
agenda apparently because
for the next for 10 minutes he threatens
that he's going to
hang up and i was like don't you [ __ ]
hang up i'm already 20 minutes invested
yeah and more and more he started
creeping over to me creeping i was like
i will [ __ ] hurt you
i will hurt you really bad were you kind
of hanging out are you kind of laughing
or were you
no i told him i was like i've been
waiting this [ __ ] long i'm invested
and it he didn't you know take heed
so he rushed me wrestled me
and hung up the phone and so i
had to retaliate i was so curious
wow nobody tells the slept king what to
do
right my gut says do it i do it and
that's a new rule
right don't [ __ ] around you know if papa
gonna say something papa gonna do it
but then he then he threatened to cancel
all his ontario shows
improv shows because he said he couldn't
walk
that's true and he told his manager he
called his manager to complain about his
leg
yes and he said i don't think i can walk
on stage i did i did
he says it's kyla's fault his fault what
did abby say
um she said i'm not doing that there's
no way i'm doing that yeah
i go you have to i can't move you want
me to not go up on stage
you know and um i know
but the thing is is that um well i did
something else like that too
oh yeah so i had to do press for ontario
right so like it's it's one radio
station which is a good one
mm-hmm what's that called hamilton
yeah it's a great morning news show i've
done it before
but it's like five in the morning i'm
like i have to go to culver city and
then go straight from culver city to
ontario to do
shows and they got me a hotel room so i
could sleep all during the day